[Music]
more than six thousand light-years from
the surface of the earth a rapidly
spinning a neutron star called the black
widow pulsar blasts its companion brown
dwarf star with radiation as the two
orbit each other every nine hours
standing on our own planet you might
think you're just an observer of this
violent ballet but in fact both stars
are pulling you towards them and you're
pulling back connected across trillions
of kilometres by gravity gravity is the
attractive force between two objects
with mass any two objects with mass
which means that every object in the
universe attracts every other object
every star black hole human being
smartphone and atom are all constantly
pulling on each other so why don't we
feel pulled in billions of different
directions two reasons mass and distance
the original equation describing the
gravitational force between two objects
was written by Isaac Newton in 1687
scientists understanding of gravity has
evolved since then but Newton's law of
universal gravitation is still a good
approximation in most situations it goes
like this the gravitational force
between two objects is equal to the mass
of one times the mass of the other
multiplied by a very small number called
the gravitational constant and divided
by the distance between them squared if
you doubled the mass of one of the
objects the force between them would
double - if the distance between them
doubled the force would be one-fourth as
strong the gravitational force between
you and the earth pulls you towards its
center a force you experience as your
weight let's say this force is about 800
Newtons when you're standing at sea
level if you traveled to the Dead Sea
the force would increase by a tiny
fraction of a percent and if you climbed
to the top of Mount Everest the force
would decrease but again by a miniscule
amount
traveling higher would make a bigger
dent in gravity's influence but you
won't escape it gravity is generated by
variations in the curvature of
space-time the three dimensions of space
plus time which bend around any object
that has mass gravity from Earth reaches
the International Space Station 400
kilometers above the earth with almost
its original intensity if the Space
Station was stationary on top of a giant
column you'd still experience 90% of the
gravitational force there that you do on
the ground
astronauts just experience
weightlessness because the space station
is constantly falling towards Earth
fortunately it's orbiting the planet
fast enough that it never hits the
ground by the time you made it to the
surface of the Moon around 400,000
kilometers away
Earth's gravitational pull would be less
than 0.03 percent of what you feel on
earth the only gravity you'd be aware of
would be the moons which is about
one-sixth as strong as the Earth's
travel farther still an Earth's
gravitational pull on you will continue
to decrease but never drop to zero even
safely tethered to the earth
we're subject to the faint tug of
distant celestial bodies and nearby
earthly ones the Sun exerts a force of
about half a Newton on you if you're a
few meters away from a smartphone you'll
experience a mutual force of a few Pico
Newtons that's about the same as the
gravitational pull between you and the
Andromeda galaxy which is 2.5 million
light years away but about a trillion
times as massive as the Sun but when it
comes to escaping gravity there's a
loophole if all the mass around us is
pulling on us all the time
how would gravity change if you tunnel
deep below the surface assuming you
could do so without being cooked or
crushed if you hollowed out the center
of a perfectly spherical earth which it
isn't but let's just say it were you'd
experience an identical pull from all
sides and you'd be suspended weightless
only encounter
the tiny poles from other celestial
bodies so you could escape the Earth's
gravity in such a thought experiment but
only by heading straight into it keep
flexing your physics muscles with this
ted-ed series in which to CERN
scientists simplifies space-time in
three short videos
[Music]